there is huge news starting to leak out
of mgm regarding stargate
welcome to sidetrack your sci-fi tv a
movie channel
[Music]
so as you'll know if you're a regular
site tracker i have people that i speak
to that work in and around mgm one or
two that work directly for mgm and one
or two that work indirectly for them and
they've been feeding the information
about some of the discussions and some
of the rumors that are going around
their offices
now today i've been given two huge
pieces of information one is fact one is
happening one is a massive rumor the
rumor i'm going to tell you about in the
next video so please if you are new to
the channel like subscribe hit the bell
notification all those things sort of
things hit the bell so you know when
that video comes up
meetings have been arranged for the week
beginning the 4th of april those
meetings are going to bring mgm and
amazon executives together now who are
those executives you might want to ask
now i have to read from my list here
because there's a lot of them
stephen bruno is the chief marketing
officer for mgm mark burnett
is the chairman worldwide tv group and
michael wright is the president of
scripted television they're going to be
meeting with executives from amazon
vernon sanders head of global tv
oklahoma ojo chief marketing officer
and jennifer sulk head of amazon studios
now there was a meeting back in november
and these people did attend but that
meeting was kind of like unofficial you
know mgm wasn't officially owned by
amazon at that point they couldn't
really tell mgm what to do
and i am actually being told by mgm
people that that isn't really the vibe
they're getting from amazon anyway the
amazon aren't really the forcing their
ideals on mgm that they continue on to
almost behave like a customer where they
will order things from mgm but they
won't necessarily get too much involved
in what that product and product would
then be they trust mgm to do what they
do which is make tv
which that was the first bit of news i
got that actually made me very very
happy but then they told me a little bit
more about this meeting for one thing i
do know somebody that works in and
around the creative side of mgm
they've told me that some preliminary
storyboarding and concept art has been
done for two scripts for two pilot
episodes now up until now we've not
known where this second pilot come from
but one name that does seem to be
attached to it
is joseph joe malozzi
the other script is obviously the brad
wright script that we already know about
this so both of those scripts both those
pilots have been scripted out now
mgm have done this basically amazon's
request because amazon have basically
said we want you to create a pilot that
is a much bigger scope than the original
brad wright project a brand right
project that was basically written to a
budget back when mgm hadn't been bought
by amazon and was in massive debt
but what is this meeting to discuss well
as i said these people have met before
but before that meeting was very
informal it was a business meeting
talking about the merger and how things
would work in the future and it was also
basically
letting the mgm executives know what the
amazon sort of standpoint was
but this meeting is different this
meeting is going to be very much about
creative direction and starting to put a
plan in place towards making some very
big decisions now i mentioned the
storyboarding because that has been
ordered for these meetings the teams
working on this art and these
storyboards have been told have
something ready for those meetings so
that it can be pitched to the executives
that is a big piece of news because
i've been told for some months now that
amazon really considers stargate to be
the sleeping giant of sci-fi but we were
never really sure whether amazon were
going to push ahead with it this news
them asking for this concept art to be
prepared for these massive meetings
really to show how important amazon
seems to think stargate is and that is
hugely exciting for us gators because we
really really want the show to be on our
screens as quickly as possible
amazon have come to mgm basically with a
proposal that they want three projects
to really push forward with immediately
one will most certainly be james bond
one will certainly be stargate and this
third big project amazon now own this
massive back catalogue of intellectual
properties and they want to push forward
with a remake or a reboot of one of
those
that is again going to be a future video
because i now happen to know the list of
the proposed projects one of those might
be and they're almost all science
fiction projects
so this is an incredibly exciting piece
of news and hopefully we're going to get
something that's not just rumor and leak
actually officially from amazon in the
next few months
these meetings will not necessarily
green light any project but they should
give us a plan they should let us know
what the structure of that plan is over
the next few months
and there is another piece of really
massive news
but that's for the next video
so if you are new to the channel please
like subscribe hit that bell
notification thumbs up thumbs down
thumbs down helps nobody and if you want
to become a fully fledged sidetracker
and support the channel please consider
hitting that join button
as always guys please stay safe
i'll see you next time
you